Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ayildiz und ich bin auf dieser Station Astral Arztätik und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen eine Rede gestreifen, bevor wir mit Ihren Beschwerden anfangen. Würde ich Ihnen ein paar personische Informationen bitten? Einverstanden?
Ja, ja bin ich.
Ich heiße Michael Horst Kotte.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname posten?
Michael schreibt sich M-I-C-H-A-E-L Michael und der Vorname Horst Kotte H-O-R-S-T-K-O-T-T-E.
Horst Kotte.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. März 1962.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Wie viel wegen Sie?
Ich wiege 93 kg.
Horst Kotte.
Was führt Sie sonst?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr 3 Wochen Schmerzen im Bereich der linken Hüfte und des linken Oberschenkels.
Die Schmerzen werden in den letzten Tagen stärker.
Seit 3 Wochen, linken Hüfte, Schmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, und im linken Oberschenkel.
Können Sie mir beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen aufgetreten sind?
Die sind langsam aufgetreten.
Wie läuft die Schmerzen mit der Zeit?
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich aufstehe und gehe, dann werden die Schmerzen stärker.
Mit der Bewegung verschlechtert Sie die Schmerzen?
Ja, Bewegung.
Hatten Sie so etwas höher schon einmal?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Wie ist die Einigung vorhanden?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Unfall habe ich auch nicht gehabt.
Können Sie mir beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen sind?
Die Schmerzen sind mehr dumpf, krampartig oder steckend.
Die Schmerzen sind mehr dumpf und bohrend.
Wenn ich mich bewege, sind sie auch etwas stechend.
Aber hauptsächlich dumpf und bohrend.
Bei Bewegung kommt manchmal ein stichartiger Schmerz.
Wollen die Schmerzen in der Körperregion ausstellen?
Nein.
Nur mit der Bewegung verschlechtert Sie die Schmerzen.
Und dann ist es ein anderes Auslöse für die Schmerzen.
Nein.
Okay.
für dich messen.
Und gibt es andere Auslöse für dich messen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und
haben Sie noch eine andere
Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel
Fieber, Steffel oder Kartenschweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, habe ich regelmäßig Stuhlgang.
Nein, habe auch keine Erbrechen.
Nein.
Wie stark
dich messen?
Auf eines zu keiner, 0 110.
Vorbei ein sehr leichter Schmerzen.
Nicht mehr,
nicht mehr,
nicht mehr, nicht mehr, nicht mehr.
Ich habe auch keine Erbrechen.
vorbei ein sehr leichter Schmerzen und 10, 60er Schmerzen.
Ja, in Ruhe würde ich sagen bei 5, in Ruhe, aber wenn ich mich bewege, dann bis 7.
Okay, und haben Sie Schwiegkeiten einzuschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, jetzt in den letzten Tagen mit den Schmerzen, da habe ich auch nachts die Schmerzen,
da kann ich auch nicht so gut schlafen. Vorher konnte ich immer gut schlafen, aber jetzt so, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, ist der Schlaf nicht so gut.
Wer ging Schwiegkeiten? Okay, Herr Horst Korte, leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe chronische Bronchitis, so seit ungefähr 4 Jahren.
Da war ich auch beim Lungenfacharzt und da wollte ich da wieder hingehen, im März habe ich da wieder einen Termin zur Kontrolle.
Ich habe auch hohe Blutdruck, so ungefähr seit 6 Jahren, dann nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Sonst bin ich noch beim Urologen, weil ich vor 3 Jahren hatte ich Prostatakrebs und das wurde operiert und bestrahlt.
Vor 5 Wochen war ich beim Urologen und da war dieser Tumormaker, dieses PSA, etwas erhöht und das soll jetzt Anfang Februar nochmal kontrolliert werden.
Sie haben chronische Bronchitis und Artillerhypertoni, wird auch zurück seit 8 Jahren und vor 3 Jahren Prostatakrebs diagnostiziert.
Und letzte Kontrolle war PCA erhöht.
PSA war etwas erhöht, aber das soll jetzt kontrolliert werden. Ich glaube der Termin ist in gut 2 Wochen.
Okay. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme einmal für die Lunge, Budesonit-Spray, das sind so Kapseln, die machen einen Apparat rein und da kommt so ein Nebel, ein Staub raus, den muss ich einatmen.
Zweimal am Tag nehme ich das und dann nehme ich manchmal auch noch Salbutamol-Spray, aber das nehme ich nicht regelmäßig.
Im Winter nehme ich es ein bisschen mehr, weil ich da mehr mit der Bronchitis-Probleme habe im Winter.
Und dann nehme ich noch Blutdruck-Tabletten, dann nehme ich Bisoprolol, da hinter steht 5 und dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends
Nehmen Sie noch eine andere Medikamente, die ich nicht mehr mit der Flasche nehmen darf?
Nein, nehme ich nicht.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind. Da war ich 10 Jahre alt, als ich am Blinteram operiert.
Und mit 12 Jahren wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert und vor 15 Jahren, wie alt war ich da?
48, 15 Jahre, da wurde ich an der Bandscheibe operiert, in der Lendenwerbelsäule, auf der linken Seite.
Aber das ist gut gegangen, da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Im Bereich Lendenwerbelsäule?
Hatten Sie damals eine N-Nichterschmerzen?
Nein, die sind etwas anders gewesen, bis in den Unterschenkel gezogen und in den Fuß.
Das war anders mit den Schmerzen, heute sind diese Schmerzen anders.
Jetzt die Geschwürfelschmerzen stammen nicht aus.
Sind Sie gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich das.
Aufrischimpfungen wurden auch gemacht, dieses Wundstarkrampf, Tethanostifterie.
Ich wurde gegen Lungenentzündung geimpft.
Das hat der Lungenarzt gesagt, das wäre wichtig für mich wegen meiner chronischen Brontitis.
Und Grippeimpfung habe ich gemacht, Corona-Impfung auch.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Herr Horst Korte, rauchen Sie?
Ich habe vor vier Jahren mit dem Rauchen aufgehört, als diese Diagnose mit der Brontitis kam.
Vorher habe ich 40 Jahre lang eine Schachtel-Zigaretten geraucht.
40 Jahre?
Denken Sie Alkohol?
Abends trinke ich eine kleine Flasche Bier.
Denken Sie nicht, Herr Sönich, aber ich muss fragen, haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Dürrgen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Postbote.
Postbote?
Im April bekomme ich meine Rente, werde ich pensioniert.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder.
Die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns, weil sie sind jetzt schon 33 Jahre alt und 35 Jahre alt.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Leben Sie zusammen mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja.
Ich habe noch eine Frage über Ihre Familie. Leben Sie noch Ihre Eltern?
Der Vater ist verstorben, im Alter von 74 Jahren ist er verstorben an Prostatakrebs.
Prostatakrebs ist mein physischer Beileid.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, dass er 74 Jahre alt ist.
Im Alter von 74 Jahren ist er verstorben.
Die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 86 Jahre alt.
Sie hat ein schweres Gelenkräumer und eine Herzmuskelschwäche.
Hat er noch eine Krankheit?
Nein, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der ist 61 Jahre alt und hat hohe Blutdruck.
Ich glaube, meine Fragen sind fertig.
Haben Sie Fragen für mich?
Was kann das sein?
Ich mache mir Sorgen, weil ich noch nie etwas hatte.
Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann werde ich ein bisschen Brut abnehmen, um eine Labo-Untersuchung durchzuführen.
Dann werde ich alle Ergebnisse mit meinem Oberarzt spüren.
Dann informiere ich Sie.
Dann haben Sie etwas Zeit, sich das zusammenzuschreiben.
Wenn Sie noch Fragen haben, können wir gerne antworten.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie hat bei Ihnen einen Seekommiss bemerkt.
Haben Sie Taupadsgefühl, Kreben oder Lehmung an der Betrufnüschterle?
Nein, das hatte ich damals bei dem Bandscheibenvorfall.
Da hatte ich so Kreppeln und Taupadsgefühl im Bein.
Aber das habe ich jetzt nicht.
Momentan.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Gibt es am Betrufnenbereich auch Hautveränderungen wie Rötung oder Schwellung?
Oder gibt es auch Bewegungseinschränkungen am Betrufnen im Bein?
Ja, ich habe jetzt nicht aufgefahren.
Aber ich kann das Bein seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr so gut bewegen.
Auch das Umdrehen im Bett ist schwieriger.
Da fühle ich mich schon eingeschränkt.
Haben Sie Geräusche bei der Bewegung des Gelenks zu hören?
Ich habe nicht mehr Geräusche bemerkt.
Ich habe keine Geräusche bemerkt.
Haben Sie auch am Leistenbereich Vergrößte der Lämpfknoten bemerkt?
Da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen haben.
Mein Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass ich da etwas abgenommen habe.
Danke schön.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
War Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland oder im Urlaub?
Ich meine eine langen Trägerfahrt mit Flugfahrt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Im letzten Sommer war ich in Deutschland am Nordsee.
Ich war im Herbst noch einmal eine Woche am Bodensee.
Ich habe keine langen Fahrt gemacht.
Sie arbeiten als Postbotser?
Sie sind eine Sitzende?
Ja, ich glaube, dass sie in Deutschland sind.
Ich habe keine Sitzende.
Ich denke, dass sie in Deutschland sind.
Überwiegend.
Früher habe ich als Postbote Briefe in die Häuser ausgeteilt.
Das würde ich heute gar nicht schaffen.
Aber ist du seit?
Ja, ich arbeite noch.
Es ist mir in den letzten Tagen sehr schwer gefallen.
Vielen Dank.
Wurden Sie in letzter Zeit Synthografie durchgeführt?
Nein, in letzter Zeit wurde keine Synthografie durchgeführt.
Es wurde damals, als die Diagnose gestellt wurde,
Prostatakrebs, da wurde auch eine Synthografie gemacht.
Vielleicht kommt das jetzt bald,
weil ich muss jetzt zur Kontrolle zu den Urologen.
Vielleicht kommt eine Synthografie?
Oder eine andere Untersuchung?
Danke.
Ja, alles gut.
Ich habe einen neuen Patenten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen den Fall kurz vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja.
Der Patent heißt Michael Horskotte.
Er ist 63 Jahre alt.
Und 184 cm groß.
Und 93 Yoga.
Herr Horskotte,
stellte sich heute bei uns seit 3 Wochen,
3 Wochen,
im linken Hüfte,
linken Oberschenkel bestehende Schmerzen vor.
Er stellte sich wegen seit 3 Wochen
bestehender Schmerzen
in der linken Hüfte und Oberschenkel vor.
Die Schmerzen
sind langsam aufgetreten.
Und dumpf und bohrend.
Die Schmerzen in der Strecke
wurden beim Bewegen
7, beim Ruhe 5,
von 10 bewertet.
Die Patenten begleitete,
dass die Schmerzen nicht in anderen Regionen schütterten.
Oder mit anderen Körperregionen wandern.
Die Schmerzen würden sich
beim Bewegung verständigen.
Oder im Linken
verschwinden.
Und
die Patent
macht eine Frage.
Der Patient.
Die Schmerzen
wegen der Schmerzen
hat der Patent
in Somnia.
Erbrechen, Übelkeit
oder zugenommen
verneint.
Kennen Sie die Fachbegriffe für Übelkeit?
Ja, in unserer Formitus.
Er hat die Schmerzen
verneint.
Und
der Patent
leidet
seit 4 Jahren
chronisch
Brunschtis.
Seit 8 Jahren
Arteilo-Hypothonie.
Und
2 Jahre Prostat Krepp.
Prostat
Katzinom, der Arteilo-Hypothonie.
Prostat Katzinom.
Und
wegen Prostat Katzinom
war letzte Kontrolle
PCA Marker
Krebsmarker erhöht.
PSA, ja PSA.
Wie wurde, wie wurde den das Prostat Katzinom behandelt?
Prostat Katzinom.
Wegen der Prostat Katzinom
wurde der Patent
operabel.
Operiert, ja operiert.
Und ich glaube,
ich habe Strahntherapie bekommen.
Man kann sagen, vor 3 Jahren
hatte der Patient, wurde bei dem Patient
ein Prostat Katzinom diagnostiziert.
Und das wurde
operiert und anschließend
mit Radiation behandelt.
Bestrahlung.
Ja, okay.
Gut, gibt es da irgendwelche, ist der Patient da in Kontrolle?
Beim Urologen oder beim Onkologen?
Ja, in 3 Wochen
in 2 Wochen
hat er eine Termin beim Urologen.
Ja, können Sie mir sagen, da war doch etwas vor einigen Wochen, war im Blut.
Ja, bitte.
Der Patient hat berichtet,
dass der PSA-Wert erhöht war.
Ja, okay, ihr habt gesagt, aber ja.
Ja, sagen Sie ruhig nochmal.
Der PSA-Wert war auffällig, leicht erhöht.
Der Patient weiß nicht genau, wie hoch.
Aber er muss zur Kontrolle zum Urologen
und das heißt in 2 Wochen.
Gut.
Und der Patient,
beide Patente,
wurde im Alter 10 Jahren
appendectomie
und im Alter von 12 Jahren
Mandel,
Mandel operiert
und die Patientin kennt Sie den Fachbegriff Mandel-Operation?
Ja, nochmal.
Kennen Sie?
Tonzi Lektomi.
Ja, okay.
Gut, das wurde der Patient sonst schon einmal operiert?
Und vor
15 Jahren
war es schon einmal operiert
im Bereich Landen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich war vor 15 Jahren
ein lumbaler Discos-Prolaps
und der wurde operiert.
Okay.
Gibt es sonstige Risikofaktoren bei den Patienten?
Wir wissen schon, er ist etwas übergewichtig,
etwas, er hat einen erhöhten Blutdruck,
eine Hypertonie,
er hat eine COPD.
Warum hat er eine COPD?
Wissen Sie das?
Eine Erklärung?
COPD, ich kann nicht verstehen.
Sorry.
COPD, chronisch obstruktive Lungenerkrankung.
Ja, deswegen
der Patient leidet an chronische Präunchtis.
Ja, wir nennen das auch COPD wahrscheinlich,
weil er bekommt ja schon
Boudisonit und so etwas, das werden Sie uns gleich noch erzählen.
Aber gibt es eine Ursache
für die COPD?
Eine Erklärung?
Der Patient
als Post-Portal-Arzt.
Post-Portal-Arzt.
Aber Sie können sagen, denken Sie an sein Nikotinkonsum.
Okay.
Ja.
Sie können sagen, bei den Patienten besteht
in der Anamnese ein langjähriger
oder ein Nikotin ab Usus von 40 Packages,
der Nikotinkonsum
wurde vor vier Jahren beendet.
Trotzdem ist das für den Patienten ein großes Risiko noch,
nach wie vor.
Gut, dass er beendet hat, aber es trotzdem gilt er noch
als Risikopatient.
Ja, was nimmt der Patient für Medikamente ein?
Der Patient
nehme regelmäßig
Bundes-Syprey
zweimal täglich
insprzonderer Winter
aber bei Bedarf, Salvatomal,
Cyprey, grünsche Brunschitis
und wegen Arterieperitone
bis zur Prolohl 5 mg
morgen und abends
und kann das dann 8 mg
morgens abends täglich
einnehmen.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienanamnese?
Ja,
beide
seine Vater
seine Vater ist
74 Jahre Prostatakrebs
wegen Prostatakrebs gestorben.
Ja, sagen Sie, am besten sagen Sie dann, Herr Kollege,
der Vater ist im Alter von 74 Jahren
an einem Prostatakarsinum verstorben.
Ja?
Der Vater
sein im Alter von
74 Jahre
an Prostatakrebs verstorben.
Prostatakarsinum?
Prostatakarsinum verstorben
und die Mutter
lebt noch
86 Jahre
und
sie leidet
an
Kardinium-Pati
und Gelenkröme
und
ja, die Mutter hat schweres Gelenkrömer, wahrscheinlich ein
zündliches Gelenkrömer, wahrscheinlich
also nicht unbedingt eine Arthrose, sondern wahrscheinlich
eine räumatoide Arthritis.
Ja?
Und Herzmuskelschwäche, okay, Kardium-Myopathie
kann man vielleicht sagen, aber man kann natürlich auch sagen,
noch häufiger ist Myokart insuffizienz.
Myokart insuffizienz.
Herzmuskelschwäche.
Die Übergänge sind wahrscheinlich fließend.
Gibt es noch Geschwister?
Ja, sein hat eine Brüder
und er
hat 61 Jahre
und leidet an
Arthritis.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Und
ich gehe von dem Fremder
auf
Prostatkalsnummer,
erwege Prostatkalsnummer
kann ich nicht sagen.
Man kann sagen, es wurde glaube ich unten schon mal geschrieben,
eventuell besteht der Verdacht auf ein metastasierendes,
Metastase, auf eine
Knochenmetastase, Ostshere-Metastasierung
oder viele Erisierung bei Prostatkalsinum.
Der Verdacht muss geäußert werden bei der Vorgeschichte.
Er hatte ein jetzt leicht erhöhtes PSA.
Wir wissen nicht genau, wie hoch das war.
Jetzt sollte mir die Kontrolle sein.
Ich finde den Abstand wie der Patient das sagt, ziemlich lang.
Kann man auch etwas engemarschiger
jetzt diagnostizieren, aber es war jetzt ja auch Weihnachten
und Silvester, dann ist das schwierig.
Also Verdacht auf
metastasierendes Prostatkalsinum
und differenzial diagnostisch?
Ja,
als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in
in den Bereich
London-Henney,
London-Henney oder
und
in Ferge.
Also in der Gegend ist ja noch ein Organ
oder ein Gelenk, was sehr häufig
beschwerden macht, das ist die Hüfte.
Er hat Hüfte beschwerden im Gebereich der Hüfte,
die in den Oberschenkel auch ausstrahlen,
teilweise oder Oberschenkelschmerz.
Es gibt es häufiger auch bei einer Cox-Artrose.
Cox-Artrose ist die Hüfte.
Alter bei den Patienten wahrscheinlich mit die
häufigste Diagnose, ja, am wahrscheinlichsten.
Aber bei der Vorgeschichte Prostata
muss man auf alle Fälle da
eine Diagnostik machen, um, das habe ich da
unten neben schon gelesen, da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, ja.
Aber diese beiden Sachen denke ich,
kommen in Betracht, Cox-Artrose und Prostatakazinom.
Ein Kollege hatte ja gefragt,
gibt es Hautveränderungen, man kann auch
eventuell an einen Herpes-Zoster denken, zum Beispiel,
der nicht immer so ganz typisch verläuft
vom Schmerzbild, aber
kann man auch daran denken. Aber ich würde sagen,
in erster Linie Prostata, in zweiter Linie Cox-Artrose.
Kennen Sie den Begriff für die Knie-Artrose,
Kniegelenks-Artrose?
Ja, nochmal.
Also vom Knie, speziell vom Knie.
Da unten wurde es geschrieben, da unten steht es drin,
Gon-Artrose.
Ich weiß, Sie kennen die Begriffe, aber Sie
jetzt abzurufen, ist jetzt etwas schwieriger.
Gut.
Ja, aber trotzdem vielen Dank, dass Sie sich
bereit erklärt haben
zum Training.
Und es ist ja immer wieder auch eine
gewisse Stresssituation.
Das ist so.
Aber ich finde, das hat sich trotzdem gut gemacht.
Ich habe Sie gut verstanden.
Versuchen Sie eben auch diese allgemeinen
Sachen, wie, das hatten Sie vergessen,
Übelkeit erbrechen, das wussten Sie, wie das heißt,
aber dass Sie das möglichst gleich von Anfang ansagen.
In der Prüfung haben Sie längere Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Das ist hier jetzt bei uns deutlich kürzer.
Und das ist in der Prüfung sicherlich etwas besser.
Dass Sie da bessere Systematik für sich haben.
Gut.
Haben Sie schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, ich habe 23. Februar.
Ja, gut.
Da haben Sie jetzt ja noch ein paar Wochen.
Das war schon ganz gut.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen einen schönen Abend.
Und wir sehen uns dann nächste Woche.
Ja, am Donnerstag wieder.
Tschüss.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Abend.